you probably go outside and notice a
very different world around you these
days a place that's much quieter and
pretty weird in this episode I wanted to
explore the idea of what this lack of
activity looks like on a planetary scale
and how the world has changed since the
virus spread across it and so we are
gonna talk to will Marshall who's the
CEO of Planet labs it's a company that
has hundreds of imaging satellites
surrounding the planet we're also going
to talk to an open-source image analyst
named Allison Poochie Oney to get her
take on what these images teach us about
what's happening and with that let's go
talk to will
[Music]
tell me a little bit about who you are
just just for people who don't know
planet and what you guys do I'm sure
planet does earth imaging satellites and
analytics on that imagery we have about
150 satellites in orbit one set the
images the entire land mass once per day
so really frequent imagery as well as 15
satellites that dedicated to higher
resolution that can zoom in on a
particular target of interest that we
have but as the virus spread across the
globe and and everybody went on lockdown
I mean you guys pretty quickly started
to post some of these images of what the
world looks like when it goes quiets
what jumped out at you as things slowed
down well the very first set of images
we were asked to take some imagery in
wuhan and just to see how dramatic that
change was from cars on the roads and on
the bridges to suddenly just gone and
then as we look round the rest of the
world from Disney to Mecca people were
just gone you were talking about people
asking for images I mean who has sort of
come to you in this type of crisis and
water what are they looking for yeah
well the first folks that were asking
for the data were the news media who
were just trying to understand
especially when they couldn't send
journalists there anymore what's going
on but then it was quickly followed by
governments who are interested in
whether or not there's anything that
could be done from early response so for
example the US government reached out
and asked if we could help monitor some
cities across the u.s. for their relief
operations in you guys I think you
redeemed an essential business during
all this so as I understand it I mean
you've been able to keep manufacturing
but then more broadly it looks like some
of the
like rocket factories have had to slow
down a little bit and I mean what has
been the knock-on effect just to the
space industry in general whether it's
its launches or satellites I would say
that space is pretty resilient for a
couple of reasons firstly it's built
very resilient Lee I mean it's very
expensive business and so on people are
very careful there's triple redundant
systems and and backups and and supply
chain management and so our company like
many other space companies are pretty
robust of where their a storm so for
example we operate all of our satellites
remotely we have remote mission control
systems that our folks can do from home
and all of that stuff is still working
the only thing that we have to do in
purses the manufacturing we've got
special permission so we can continue to
do that and then I think a second part
of it is that the space sector is very
connected with government needs whether
that's in communication satellites or in
earth observation or what-have-you and
governments in these sorts of times tend
to spend more not less both to stimulate
the economy and because they're very
necessary for emergency response
I know that you think pretty broadly
about humanity in general and you know
what is this experience been like what I
don't know what's what struck you the
most over the the past couple weeks well
look this is a extraordinary time it's
almost like a real time test of the
competence of government and that's very
interesting to see how it evolves where
countries like South Korea get on with
testing very quickly and lockdown early
they're going to do better than the
countries that fail to do those things
and that's not an experiment you want to
run the expense of human lives but we
are seeing it but then there are some
silver lining and I think that it's
important in any disaster to look for
those opportunities
it's like humanity is testing its reflex
and emergency response muscle and a bit
of strength thing that is a good idea
because we're gonna see more emergencies
come up because of climate change we're
gonna see many more big scale disasters
happen where the floods or hurricanes or
fires and we're gonna need to be able to
sponsor them this is a test of how
humans can change their behavior like
stopping flying like doing much more
virtual meetings like potentially
consuming less I do hope that through
this humanity will be a little bit more
focused on the environment and our
imagery is of course extremely important
for that
[Music]
you're an open-source image analyst can
you tell us what that means and sort of
what you do so there are a number of
different satellites in space that any
one of us can get access to you can call
up somebody with a credit card and say
hey I want an image of this and I look
at those pictures and I try to find
interesting patterns of life I've always
been on the more security end of that
whether that means looking for Naval
Weapons in China or low-intensity
conflict in Africa or even refugee
displacement these these images used to
be kind of rare and precious and prized
and mostly government or classified yeah
these things weren't available at this
quantity until honestly in the last five
years but now you have all sorts of
countries that are building their own
satellite industry and we are able to
benefit from this sort of emergence of
transparency like we've never been able
to before and so when something like
when there's this this big global story
is there anything that's popped out to
you during the last couple weeks yeah
there has been I think a couple of the
images over Iran that showed what I
think the washington post call burial
hits of a number of people being gary
but it is over a cemetery and they are
not really mass graves and they're not
really burial hits what we're seeing is
basically a country that had people died
in February from the pandemic and they
hastily buried them but they buried them
individually and they had an
individually marked graves so it sounds
like part of what you're saying is
either some part of the media was was
either sensationalizing this or just
didn't fully understand the context of
what they were seeing or like the right
the right way to talk about this I would
just say tread carefully because we're
looking at a catastrophe we're looking
at a pandemic and these are people who
don't have a disregard for their dead
they are there on the worst days of
their lives
in this particular case is this
somewhere that that's looked at on a
daily basis so resolution or the clarity
I guess to see graves being the dub we
we need I res Aleutian satellite there
used to be literally five
high-resolution satellites in the early
2010 and now I've lost count I think
there are 36 37 so any given point in
New York surface we used to be able to
see twice a year and now we can probably
see roughly twice a week or maybe five
or six times of showings or what the
world looks like when it comes to a
standstill and all these places today
they jump out at you just because you
have such a keen eye for this stuff yeah
I'm actually working with a number of
organizations who are trying to do a
covin response using satellite imagery
the analytics teams at places like
planet they are doing metrics are people
populating certain areas really
interesting details that can augment
municipal information that we already
have and then you can actually do things
that allow people to learn whether
people are sheltering in place or not
one is cell data records or a tracking
cell phone data which has been a very
effective tool in showing how people are
traveling from their home in certain
countries the cell phone records are
tracking to hospitals versus grocery
stores so if you see that in one County
people are still going to the grocery
store more than the hospital then maybe
that means there hasn't been a big
outbreak there yeah and yet we have to
ask ourselves the ethical question is
this okay right now if this can if we
can track people and potentially put
like shelter and place orders in certain
regions that could have the potential to
save lives is that more important than
some someone's autonomy or you know or
secrecy we're in this interesting moment
when there's a lot more truth about the
world that can be gleaned through data
yeah I mean it just like if someone
who's watched this virus play out what
have you well I mean you bring up a
really interesting point when the
Washington Post for instance among a lot
of other news organizations published
the saddle
injury over the cemetery in Iran there
was a very strong slant on Iran has been
obfuscating the actual numbers of people
who had perished from coronavirus and
this satellite imagery shows that
there's a fair not more people that have
perished from coronavirus
satellite imagery does fold people's
leaders in fact feet to the fire because
it's possible now for civilians right
and for academic institutions to check
so it would at the very least force
people to be more transparent about
what's actually going on in their
country